[Música]
tiempo para la información económica
aquí en directo América me acompaña
nuestro compañero Juan Pablo lucumé Juan
vamos a comenzar con la noticia del día
en el mundo de la economía ese nuevo
plan que presentó el nuevo ministro de
finanzas ayer nijander Reino Unido en el
que ya retira ese polémico mini
presupuesto que había presentado
inicialmente la Premier porque lo hizo
Así es Juan buenas noches es básicamente
lo hizo para calmar los mercados el
nuevo ministro económico revocó casi por
completo El polémico mini presupuesto de
50 mil millones de dólares que buscaba
recortes Fiscales sin fundamento de
financiación y que le costó a Reino
Unido una caída de la libra esterlina
ataques al gobierno británico y hasta
llamados de atención del fondo monetario
internacional y el banco de Inglaterra
el viernes pasado la primera ministra
listross sacó de funciones al ministro
de finanzas cuasi cuarten con quien
propuso este polémico plan y le dio le
dio la bienvenida a Jeremy Hunt hablemos
entonces de ese nuevo plan que propone
precisamente ayer y mi Hunt Pues el plan
Busca una recaudación de 36 mil millones
de dólares de forma anual la eliminación
del impuesto sobre la renta y la
reducción del plan del tope de precio de
la energía también se planea que el
banco de Inglaterra de Inglaterra
reanude la venta de bonos corporativos
escuchemos
en primer lugar daremos marcha atrás a
casi todas las medidas Fiscales
anunciadas en el plan de crecimiento de
Hace tres semanas que no han iniciado la
legislación parlamentaria así mientras
que continuaremos con la supresión de la
tasa de asistencia sanitaria y social y
los cambios en el impuesto sobre el
timbre ya no Seguiremos adelante con los
recortes de los tipos impositivos sobre
los dividendos la reversión de las
reformas del trabajo fuera de nómina
introducidas en 2017 y 2021 el nuevo
plan de compras sin iva para Los
visitantes de fuera de Reino Unido o la
congelación de los tipos impositivos
sobre el alcohol sin duda alguna una de
las primeras grandes crisis que enfrenta
la listro hacen lo poco que lleva en el
gobierno británico pero ella que dice
respecto porque al comienzo ya
respaldaba ultranza obviamente de su
plan Así es pues la Premier británica de
tan solo Pues que lleva 40 días un poco
más tuvo que pedir perdón la Disculpa
también la hizo de forma pública así
como de forma pública en su momento
apoyo el mini presupuesto Esto fue lo
que dijo
en lo que me enfoco es en entregarle
resultados al pueblo británico
ahora Reconozco que he cometido errores
lo siento por ellos pero lo sé arreglado
he seleccionado un nuevo líder hemos
restablecido la estabilidad económica y
la disciplina fiscal y lo que quiero
hacer ahora es entregarle al público
fuimos elegidos en respuesta a la
voluntad de 2019 estoy determinada
entregar con base en eso y asegurar la
inversión en todos los lugares de
nuestro país construir vías conseguir
oportunidades en las Naciones Eso es en
lo que me estoy enfocando
uno después de ese día tan agitado para
la premiere para suministro de finanzas
Cuáles son las reacciones en el
territorio británico pues Juan primero
vamos a los mercados bursátiles porque
las bolsas europeas cerraron en terreno
positivo con indicador más famoso de
Reino Unido el 100 reportando un 0,90 de
ganancias el anuncio de Jeremy Hunt Pues
de que las decisiones tomarían los
mercados en realidad si lo hizo o al
menos por hoy la noticia también relajó
a los inversores de Wall Street en donde
se registraron importantes ganancias en
sus tres principales indicadores los
tres ganaron más del uno dos y tres por
ciento pero los ciudadanos británicos
opinaron de forma negativa
creo que el partido conservador en su
conjunto tiene que hacer un gran
replanteamiento están en un lío terrible
no sé muy bien que salió mal es
aterrador Pero a dónde vamos quiero
decir ahora somos un país del Tercer
mundo en todos los asuntos política
riqueza salud y adultos mayores Tengo 28
años pero estoy preocupada por mi futuro
estoy preocupada por mis hijos estoy
preocupada por la estructura de este
país siento que estamos retrocediendo
nos vamos a convertir en un país del
Tercer mundo
dejamos el Reino Unido y vamos a hablar
ahora de Estados Unidos porque parece
desgraciadamente casi un hecho que este
país en los próximos 12 meses va a
entrar en esa temida recesión si es casi
inminente pues proyecciones de bloombert
económicas económicas dicen que hay una
probabilidad del 100% que para octubre
de 2023 Estados Unidos caiga en una
recesión el anuncio llega casi como un
golpe para el presidente Joe biden quien
ha tratado de mostrar un panorama seguro
antes de las elecciones intermedias de
noviembre Juan Pablo descifra del día
son siete mil euros eso es lo que
representará ahora el bono ecológico
para los hogares franceses que compren
auto eléctrico un anuncio que hizo el
presidente francés Emmanuel macron bajo
el marco del salón del automóvil en
París celebrado esta semana Juan Pablo
con la información económica Muchas
gracias nosotros continuamos aquí en
directo América